pathetic simpish behavior that I see in
a lot of Muslims they are donating
thousands and thousands of dollars in
super chats to these channels that have
been researching Islam for 10 years five
years making videos and then they're
still like why I still won't convert to
it like they're overtly I'm not gonna
name any names now they're overtly
definitely disobedient American bro and
these people there's kids dying in Syria
in Lebanon and uh it breaks my heart
seeing all these ads and campaigns and
we should all be giving sadaka but
instead this is where we're giving our
money to
if you guys don't have anything to say
let's address the elephant in the room
which is about this almost pathetic
simping behavior that I see I want to
give a very clear disclaimer me Rami on
how we are never going to judge
someone's Islam someone's sincerity that
is between them and Allah but it goes
without saying that there are insincere
YouTubers insincere maybe non-muslim
YouTubers could be Christian YouTubers
could be atheist YouTubers
that have kind of jumped on this
bandwagon of reacting to Islamic content
for views
now mind you another disclaimer because
people are so damn sensitive we are not
talking about the people that are
genuinely speaking knowledge we are not
talking about the people that want to
learn about Islam we are talking about
the people that are genuinely reacting
to sensationalized things you know
non-muslim reacts to this and that which
is fine but then they actually never
make the intention to do it for the sake
of Allah or for themselves to learn this
knowledge but rather super chats rather
let me make a lot of money with YouTube
views let me get clout let me get status
this is a very fast way to grow because
let's be honest The Tao scene is popping
and a lot of these people use this for
personal gain but if only they knew that
they're trading something else which is
way more important it's a two-sided coin
on one side you see it as like oh well
what they may be doing it for views and
for money and all this but they could
potentially be guided from this Allah
knows and we do not but then on the
other side there's the fact that they
are doing this for money or for views
and Allah knows best and at that point
it's like you are
you're essentially trying to use the
religion you're trying to sell it
for a small piece of this Dunya which I
mean it's even said about that in the
Quran
um I don't really have a problem if you
look at people want to use Islam for
views in the sense that they're reacting
to like our videos and saying wow that's
great or reacting to many prophets one
message your Muhammad hijab and saying
wow that's amazing I didn't know that go
for it I personally even if you have the
wrong intention I personally don't care
because all they're doing is spreading
the truth whether they like it or know
it or not if they have a bad intention
and Allah may just be using them to
guide any of their viewers anyone maybe
they're the anonymous viewers that see
their Channel and they even if the
viewer ends up hating Islam later or not
the viewer the Creator ends updating for
you later yeah there could be viewers
that watch and say well actually I agree
with this stuff I think it's something
Allah guides them because that all boils
down to Allah guide who he will so at
the end of the day you have people even
like you know after the the passing of
the process early on that would
fabricate a Hadith about the process and
I'm going to use the dean to their
advantage in Advantage but they was laid
up straight up lie you know and Allah
talks about people the Quran who write
the scripture with their own hand and
they're just basically selling it for a
little bit in this world and basically a
punishment Allah will deal with these
people right Allah never tells us go do
this to them go do that to them Allah
tells us in the Quran spread the truth
of Islam speak the truth even if it's
against yourself or the wealthy or
whatever Allah says to um obviously you
know if you don't know like I mentioned
with information is coming from if you
don't know if it's authentic justify it
make sure that it is true and um and
many other things that show us how to go
about this but never does Allah say you
know you know throw these people away or
whatever because it's possible that
people accept Islam for worldly Reasons
I'm talking about except actually saying
the except Islam for worldly reasons and
then later action enters their heart I
100 agree with you bro I can see to your
point and I agree that at the end of the
day there could be a Creator let's say
that's making Islamic content and they
might be in sincere they don't care
about they don't care about sincerity in
Islam but people find Islam through
these videos I agree with you 100 that
it's very beneficial
but I'm more alluding to the fact that
this pathetic simpish behavior that I
see in a lot of Muslims they are
donating thousands and thousands of
dollars in super chats to these channels
that have been researching Islam for 10
years five years making videos and then
they're still like why I still won't
convert to it like they're overtly I'm
not gonna name any names now they're
overtly definitely disobedient and
arrogant bro and these people there's
kids dying in Syria in Lebanon and uh it
breaks my heart seeing all these ads and
campaigns and we should all be giving
sadaka but instead this is where we're
giving our money to
bro is this is this what Allah has put
us here with the gift and blessing of
Islam for bro
yeah I um I I agree at that point as
well and there have been cases that I've
heard of where people either accept
Islam or talk a lot about Islam and then
start some kind of donation or charity
or GoFundMe and they raise a lot of
money and then instantly change after
they get x amount of money Allah you
know Allah these people I don't think we
should be donating to these people like
that just because we're looking into
Islam
um but at the same time I'm not I'm from
that point right I'm not I'm not giving
any specifications where you can do that
I don't think we should donate to these
people like for these reasons
um on the sub note I've spoken to you
know these people before and one person
in particular
um who did all those things you know
reviewed Islam and talked about this and
that and made videos why I'm not Muslim
I've spoken to one of those people very
recently
um uh actually they reached out to me
about this
um and I've been discussing with them
you know evidence of Islam and things
more in depth because you know a lot of
these people they see surface level
things on you know online they don't
actually get to the deep understanding
of Islam maybe some of the information
they heard is actually wrong you know
they're not actually studying Islam
properly not going to Scholars they're
not really getting proper answers and I
think that's that's why this person
reached out to me and based on my
conversation with them I could see that
um so every case is particular but I
agree with your point that we shouldn't
just be basically throwing money in
super chats of these people because
we're looking into Islam it would be
much better to like go to like you know
Islam net or Muhammad hijab or sapiens
Institute or I3 Institute where people
are doing good work for the sake of
Allah they are Muslim they're bringing
more Muslims to Islam they're teaching
Muslims how to give double to bring more
people to Islam donate to them donate to
the people of of Syria and Yemen like
you mentioned instead is definitely much
much better there's more hair in
donating to Muslim content creators that
are actually correct trying to have a
sincere intention trying to put forward
the message of the prophecy Islam and of
Islam because these people know what
they're doing with their views with
their influence with their reach and
inshallah Their audience and then
attention is sincere may Allah protect
from that
um from not having it sincere I mean but
if it's sincere then I think it's much
more fruitful than just donating to
someone that's just watching and
reciting reacting to the Quran which is
nothing wrong by the way but I'm talking
about the level of I guess almost the
simpish behavior to the point where we
need validation from these people
and this brings me to another sub point
and there's that people are looking at
non-muslim Celebrities influencers
people that are openly disrespecting
Islam like Jordan Peterson and just
looking for a crumb bro just crumbs of
validation
please please show me Islam is correct
show me that you know you actually
believe in Islam you actually see it too
so have you guys experienced anything
with that in the YouTube scene that
people are almost idolizing these people
and just almost needing them to validate
Islam
I think it's it's just been a huge trend
for the last like two decades
um there are some cases where I think
it's a bit valid like with Keith Moore
who is an um embryology like specialist
and he was speaking about how the Quran
gets like the embryological development
of the feet is correct I think that has
grounds and that's fair because he's a
professional but not because he's a
non-muslim obviously I think there was
an aspect where people are like you know
look at this non-muslim who must be
unbiased because he's not a Muslim and
he's saying this it must be true I I
don't think that we should use people's
people being a Muslim or not being a
Muslim as grounds for whether we should
believe them or not whether they're
unbiased or not because at the end of
the day you would not know something
like that you could have a Muslim that
is unbiased like genuinely I believe I'm
a Muslim who's unbiased that literally
based on the evidence I have seen
believe Islam is the truth right but
you'll have people that look at me and
others and will say well he's a Muslim
obviously he's going to preach Islam and
he was born into it whatever so I think
likewise just because someone's not a
Muslim doesn't mean we should go be like
oh my God look at them they're praising
Islam this is such a big victory like um
Andrew Tay before I became a Muslim
people were idolizing him and and trying
to say like oh my god look the top G
said this about Islam and you know
alhamdulillah is a Muslim
which means he's more valid now
alhamdulillah
um but before Yanni like who cares like
he's a non-muslim or not just him or the
non-muslim speaking about Sam positively
why do you need to you know praise these
people above and beyond you know that is
online and what they say about Islam
hmm
knows very well said bro alone about it
what about you
you know Mommy said it perfectly bro
perfect there's a comment here um yeah
sorry really quickly sure um I can't
find it but uh someone mentioned you
know the Muslims here
uh the way the Muslims sent over Jordan
Peterson who turned out to be blown
Zionist was truly pathetic bro don't say
the Z word now come on
um
leave me alone man leave me alone but um
yeah like that's that's very true he
spoke to Mohammed a job once twice and
everyone's like oh my god look he's
open-minded he's speaking he's talking
he's having a conversation
um when you listen to the conversation
you notice that he's very unfair in his
and when he speaks about Islam or even
when he listens to Islam when he
Converses about stem he has all these
crazy questions like what do you mean
when you ask do you believe in god what
does that mean it's like bro that's such
a crazy question like yes Define what
you mean by God
maybe Define belief but like relax like
that's it's such a straightforward
question don't beat around the bush and
then he straight up brought the Prime
Minister President or whatever of a very
specific nation in the Middle East thus
not a Muslim or Arab nation and um
completely
let him spew nonsensical garbage
to diligent delegitimize the Palestinian
struggle
that's that's a big L that's I think the
Muslim community supported them in that
way it took and mailables you know
speakers like
who is actively dissecting these and
speaking out against these things like
Jordan Peterson Muhammad as well you
know he didn't just speak with him he he
made a reputation recent as well